[Music]
thank you
this is Ian King live with a special
podcast Edition from the podcast show in
North London today's top business
stories
significant easing of inflation to 8.7
but food price Rises remain stubbornly
high
marks and Spencer to resume dividend
payments as sales beat expectations
SSE announces plans to invest up to 40
billion pounds in low-carbon energy
infrastructure Plus
when we first started out all we had was
each other and no songs no Roxanne no
message in a bottle no no Every Breath
You Take he hadn't started writing them
yet
the rise of the podcast why do it
yourself programming has become such big
business
[Music]
good morning and welcome to Ian King
live today we're broadcasting from the
podcast show in North London podcasting
has enjoyed meteoric growth in recent
years and this event is an International
Festival marking Europe's biggest
Gathering of the global podcasting
Community well Sky News is here to
highlight the growing importance of
podcasting in journalism in the next
hour we'll also be exploring podcasting
as a business where the money's being
made what makes for a successful podcast
and where the industry goes from here
among my guests Melinda whitstock Tim
Burgess from the charlatans and The Rock
on tours team Gary Kemp and Guy Pratt
but before all of that there's been a
significant fall in inflation this
morning back to single digits for the
first time since last summer the office
for National statistics said the decline
was mainly driven by gas and electricity
costs remaining stable in April compared
with the huge rise recorded in the same
month last year
well the CPI measure of inflation fell
to 8.7 in April that was down from 10.1
percent in March but food inflation
remains stubbornly High dropping ever so
slightly to 19 which remains close to a
45 year high
whilst it is welcome that the headline
rate of inflation has fallen these
numbers show there is absolutely no room
for complacency in the battle against
inflation food price inflation is still
worryingly high that's why we've had
food producers in farmers in
supermarkets in to talk about what we
can do to reduce the pressure there we
are looking at why food prices are just
as high as they are and why inflation
remains High because that's such an
acute source of pressure on family
finances
well joining me now Sandra horsefield
she's an economist at investex Sandra I
guess that the story here is that while
inflation's coming down it is uh coming
down more slowly than we expected
that's right unfortunately the fact that
inflation fell is the only good news in
this report uh we know already that the
fact that electricity prices and gas
prices didn't rise uh as they did last
year with the main factor that would
pull down inflation but we didn't see is
other categories falling Goods price
inflation service price inflation those
are the parts on top of food prices they
are still very sticky and that's
disappointing
yeah and I mean the rather really
concerning aspects I guess is that core
inflation which is the measure that
strips out uh volatile elements like
energy food drink alcohol and tobacco
that actually Rose from 6.2 to 6.8
percent
that's absolutely correct it's the
rising core inflation which is much more
under the control of central banks than
uh overall inflation where you know
Energy prices be a big part um and food
uh price links do as well and on that
front that we have seen yet another jump
uh when that's the part where you think
monetary policy has more for bite is
disappointing and has clear implications
as far as monetary policy makers are
concerned so in that sense it's a
disappointment not just to market
economists but also to the bank of
England
absolutely I mean that's the key point I
mean the Market's currently pricing at
at least one more quarter point rise in
uh interest rates does this actually
potentially put half a point on the
table again
well we see the chance of the bank
deciding to go as far as that as pretty
low
um there's very few certainties in the
current environment of course but we do
see an easing in the labor market we see
signs for instance in vat receipts uh
recently that economy May indeed be
starting to slow but it's simply not
enough for the time being probably
proceeding uh with another 25 base Point
rate hike will be enough we have to
remember the level of rate that's much
higher now than it was so it's no need
to go quite as aggressively as this but
we're probably not at the end yet in
terms of the tightening cycle
Sandra what about your own inflation
forecast where do you see inflation
going from here
well there's still further signs uh we
think that this is not the end of the
full inflation but that will get
significant further declines as the year
progresses uh for start when we look at
the energy price slide
um we not only have had the energy price
guarantee but a big decline in wholesale
prices and that should mean that come
the Autumn will see yet another big step
down in the energy price inflation so
that's good news food prices too there
are some hopeful signs for instance
um in terms of wholesale packets for
wheat Etc that they're big declines that
could come at some point how long it
takes is hard to tell we see an easing
and supply chain disruptions and that's
having an impact on producer price
inflation so there are a number of
factors here that should pull inflation
considerably lower but to Target
unfortunately that will take some time
uh yet so we won't quite get there
um in the very near term not soon enough
unfortunately unfortunately
all right Sandra could leave it there
good to talk to us ever this morning
thank you thanks
now to the world of podcasting then
joining me here at the podcast show in
North London is Ross Adams he's chief
executive of stockholm-based a cast one
of the world's leading podcast hosting
and monetization platforms founded in
2014 it collaborates with podcasters and
content creators to develop exclusive
shows or assist in the production
process it's also been a champion of the
open podcast ecosystem ever since
supporting making podcasts available on
any listening platform Ross welcome to
you thank you I think you've just gone
above 100 000 podcasts on your your
platform what's driving growth right now
you know I think podcasting is a
burgeoning industry you know I think
it's just an early start of the curve
um you know acast has delivered almost
quarter of a billion dollars back to the
crater industry so we're seeing a lot
more creators come into the space which
is why we've hit over a hundred thousand
podcasts now what about the
profitability of the business is all
this activity driving profits growth as
well as revenues I mean we're a
nine-year-old business we've invested
heavily in podcasting and like I said an
early curve we're still a loss making
company but there are many profitable
podcasts out there and we're helping
drive a huge amount for the crater
industry I mentioned the fact that
you've been an advocate of the open uh
ecosystem if you like how for the
uninitiated why is that important so
podcasting is a medium like no other it
distributes via something called RSS so
it's the hosting companies like us that
host the file when you push play on an
Apple podcast or a Spotify it fetches it
from us and then we send it across the
open Eco system now there's certain
players who want to govern and uh have
podcasts just for their platform for us
we believe that a listener should be
able to listen to a podcast on any
platform and we distribute everywhere so
we believe in the open ecosystem so what
are the threats to that so I think you
know these platforms that want to
gatekeep content to one platform
podcasting is a 20 plus year old medium
that has grown up in an open ecosystem
and it's different from other mediums so
it's not going to follow the same uh
kind of rules as the likes of music has
done
um and you know you've got millions of
content created that own their own IP so
it has to exist in an open ecosystem
what about the role of advertising in
all this how important a revenue
generator are they it's hugely
podcasting is free so you can access
podcasts uh anywhere you'd like to for
free now the way that these podcasters
make money and the way that we make
money as a as a company is that we
dynamically insert adverts and we
associate brands with certain podcasts
so they get the kind of influence of the
podcast to talk about
um uh an advert so we split that Revenue
directly with the industry and that's
how the industry is held up today there
are subscriptions and there's live and
there's merch with the biggest part of
the industry is the advertising sector
and our advertisers are interested in in
broadcasting as they were 12 months ago
definitely I mean you look at the the
show today it's absolutely huge and I
think the industry is growing year after
year even in a a year where most mediums
are down podcasting is still up you know
last year roughly two billion dollars
was delivered in podcasting so it's
still in the early stages but the money
is across from radio and digital media
because they understand the environment
that podcast is it's you know it's a
beautiful space and just the type of
advertising differ dramatically from
other forms of media not really I mean
the beauty is about podcasting you've
got everything from news to sports so
there's a whole variety of advertisers
that come into the space but it is still
in the early Innings you know the kind
of commercial industry is probably 9 10
years old so podcast is a advertisers
still yet to try podcasting so it's
still burgeoning but you know it's a two
bundler industry and it's definitely
growing where do you think the industry
goes from here I mean I think it's going
to get even bigger and bigger you know
we're seeing more and more creators
creating content we're seeing more and
more listeners come into the space I
mean you look at UK as an isolated
Market Market one in four people listen
to podcasts you listen look at Radio 80
to 90 listen to kind of commercial radio
so it's got a long way to go to catch up
with those mediums which is why it's in
the early Innings but it's definitely
once you discover podcasting you you
deep you jump right in so do you the
sort of independent streak that ran
through podcasting in its early days has
been eroded I mean bit by bit that the
tech Giants have exerted more more
influence on this sector as the years
have gone on haven't they yeah they have
done but I think this is the beauty of
podcasting you know millions of creators
who own their own IP it's not like the
music industry where you sign four
contracts and you've got 95 of the
world's music on your platform you know
for us you've got to sign five million
independent podcasts if you want them
just your platform the beauty of RSS is
you can take that RSS and you distribute
it everywhere and you can have access to
the world's content instantly so for us
I don't see that as a threat I see that
as a actually helping accelerate the
industry because they're bringing more
Spotlight to the industry all right Ross
gotta leave it there good to see you
this morning best of luck for the rest
of the event thank you
uh some of today's other business news
stories for you now and the renewable
energy generator SSE said today is
planning to invest up to 40 billion
pounds in low carbon energy
infrastructure during the next decade
the company which is currently building
the world's largest offshore wind farm
at dogger Bank in the North Sea said it
at a fully funded 18 billion pound
five-year investment plan to 2027 but
was likely to end up investing more than
that the company is expecting to create
more than one thousand new green jobs
every year During the period Well the
news came as SSE reported pre-tax
profits of 2.2 billion pounds for the
year to the end of March that was up 89
on the same period a year earlier the
company invested a record 2.8 billion
pounds during the year the shares are
currently ahead by someone and
three-quarter percent
and she has a mocks and Spencer is shot
up by nearly nine percent this morning
after the retailer said it would be in a
position to resume dividend payments
this year m s which has not paid a
dividend since the 2019-20 financial
year reported a 7.8 decline in full year
pre-tax profit before one-off
adjustments to 482 million pounds that
was for the year to the first of April
it reflected higher costs and came
despite a 9.9 rise in sales to just shy
of 12 billion pounds but that was
actually better than the market had been
expecting m s food sales were ahead by
8.7 percent while sales of clothing and
home Rose by eleven and a half percent
Stuart Machin the chief executive said
that m s had outperformed the market in
Foods while in clothing and home the
stores giant was benefiting from a more
confident approach to buying and a focus
on the modern mainstream customer that
was starting to drive better style
perceptions
the owner of B and Q this morning blamed
unusually wet weather in March for a
drop in quarterly sales at the
do-it-yourself chain Kingfisher said
that during the three months to the end
of April sales at B and Q had fallen by
one and a half percent to 980 million
pounds with demand for items such as
garden and Outdoors products hit but
Thierry Garnier the chief executive said
it was a good performance given the
impact of weather on seasonal sales
Kingfisher which is Europe's largest DIY
retailer said that overall sales in the
period were ahead by four-fifths of one
percent with its Screwfix business
trading well and seen particularly
strong demand from trade customers the
shares are currently off by one and
three quarter percent
and higher energy and chemicals prices
and the cost of hiring more workers to
tackle leakages has led to a drop in
profits at seven Trends the supplier of
water and sewage services to the
Midlands and parts of Wales reported a
free tax profit of 167.9 million pounds
for the year to the end of March that
was down nearly three thirty nine
percent on the same period 12 months
earlier we'll live Garfield the chief
executive acknowledged that the industry
had not moved quickly enough on sewage
spills but said the company was making
good progress in dealing with the issue
now the shares are currently off by
someone and a quarter percent
now there's a podcast for just about
everyone whether you're into history
comedy technology business or politics
but so much Choice creates challenges
for consumers in selecting what to go
for and for podcasters themselves in
getting listeners to stick around and
increase their engagements the platform
protopolo which carries hundreds of
millions of episodes from more than 5
million podcasts claims to be tackling
that with the use of AI it was founded
by Melinda whitstock a former journalist
with the BBC the times and our sister
channel CNBC and she joins me now
Melinda welcome to you very nice to be
here now this platform was built out of
your experiences as a podcaster yes
exactly I've been a journalist for a
very long time I suppose I'm a
recovering journalist recovering TV
anchor but I'm also an entrepreneur this
is my fifth business at the intersection
of media and technology and I've always
been intrigued by how to use things like
AI to really improve the experience not
only for listeners and viewers of
podcasts but also for the podcasters
themselves 98 of whom struggle to make
money from their podcasts which is
incredible before we talk about
photopolo let's talk about your
experiences under asset podcast because
I mean you had a very well I mean you
still do it uh wings of uh inspired
success all about female entrepreneurs
what was the Genesis for that yes you
know I wanted the podcast that I wish I
had had as a female founder in
technology there are not many of us it's
very difficult for women to get Venture
Capital only two percent of women
Founders get Venture of capital and I
decided I wanted to affirm and acclaim
the journeys of female Founders who've
built seven eight and nine figure
businesses
um and I'm worried to begin with would
there be enough that I would interview
it's 810 episodes in now and I find it's
a wonderful experience not only to pass
on the learnings my own learnings but
also of all the guests
um it's also created a lot of business
for all those women that have been
interviewed so it feels good it feels
like a big give back but I mean that is
quite incredible you've done 810
episodes I mean a lot of podcasts make
it no further than a dozen uh-huh that's
true and that's actually a big problem
in the industry because what happens is
people launch a podcast because they
have a mission they have something they
have the transformation that they want
to make in the world or they launch a
podcast to grow their business
um for those the vast majority with
admissions something that they want to
say or do or educate or whatever
um they're not marketers they're not
entrepreneurs they're not business
people so they launched this podcast and
they fade because they don't know how to
be an SEO expert they don't know how to
do all the marketing uh it leads to a
lot of burnout and they don't really
necessarily understand what it takes to
monetize the podcast and that's a major
reason for founding podopolo as well
because can we make it easy for people
to do that and that's what our AI does
so how do you utilize AI yeah a couple
of ways first it Powers a recommendation
engine that offers very personalized
recommendations to People based on their
interests their friend relationships
perhaps their location their
demographics and this is very important
because people struggle to to find
podcasts that are you know interesting
to them so that makes it much easier for
The Listener and viewer to find content
that's relevant to them especially when
the app has it's actually six million
podcasts now in Audio and Video in all
languages and such right so makes it
easier for them to navigate and find
what they're interested in that same
technology though acts like a Matchmaker
it allows the podcasters to be put in
front of the exact right audiences that
are already interested in their shows so
they can be discovered by the right
people it helps them really grow and
enhance Their audience panopolo is also
socially interactive so there's a way
for users to create clips of podcasts
and easily share a 30-second bite with
somebody else and spark a conversation
about it put learning into action and
the other way that the AI really makes a
difference is deep audience insights
most podcasters are lacking data about
who Their audience actually is what they
care about so we're the only platform
that provides a full transparent kind of
single source of truth I guess about
their podcast what about the advertisers
do do you help them as well in terms of
targeting people 100 so again that same
AI technology takes the guesswork out of
advertising up until now it's been like
a numbers game where a podcaster needs a
really large audience because nobody
knows who's listening not really and The
Advertiser doesn't know the podcast or
doesn't know so imagine for a moment
that you actually do know and say the
podcast only has a thousand listeners
they could be the exact right listeners
for a particular Advertiser so we're
able to match make there and deliver
contextual advertising uh that the
audience of a podcast would be
interested in so it's better for the
listener better for the podcaster but
for the advertiser it's predictive they
get a much better return and also the AI
allows for brand safety because we know
exactly what's going on in each episode
because we're able to tag the content of
each episode in real time Melinda we're
going to leave it I'm afraid great to
see you this morning thanks very much
for joining me
[Music]
well last night's falls on Wall Street
amid concerns over the US debt ceiling
were followed by declines overnight for
equities in the age of Pacific region
most of the indices were in negative
territories you can see they're all the
main indices in the region were lower
Hong Kong and Shanghai each fell by at
least one and a quarter percent well in
Europe stocks are also in negative
territory right now talking points in uh
Continental the day there aren't that
many of them to be honest there you go
that's the uh indices all of them are
down by one percent or more actually uh
embracer which is a you a games
developer in Sweden the shares down some
37 in Stockholm right now that is on
news that a major strategic partnership
it's been promising will not now be
taking place
well here in London the ftse 100 is also
in negative territory now currently off
by just over one and a half percent in a
broad-based sell-off led by the house
builders Taylor wimpy and persimmon are
among the leading Blue Chip fallers
right now Taylor wimp as you can see
they're off by some five and a quarter
percent that's all on the back of the
inflation numbers today
um markets starting to uh worry again
about possible interest rate Rises so
that is why the builders are down there
are only a couple of gainers to mention
in the footsie I mentioned one of them
earlier on SSE the energy generator up
nearly one percent well at the bottom of
the screen there you can see intertek
that's the quality testing and Assurance
group the shares are up nearly three
percent there right now on a trading
update outside the ftse 100 London
metric property is down by some 6.3
percent uh that is uh on the back of uh
agreeing to buy small arrival for 198.6
million pounds m s one of the few rays
of sunshine in the mid cap index today
look at that the shares now some 13
higher on the session on the foreign
exchange markets for the big talking
point today has actually been the New
Zealand dollar which fell back overnight
after the country's Central Bank Corp
markets on the hop by suggesting it's
done with raising interest rates for now
the pound is virtually unchanged as you
can see there against both the dollar
it's about a tenth of one percent lower
right now against the Euro single
currency unchanged me one more or less
against the dollar as for the oil price
well that rallied overnight as comments
from Saudi Arabia's energy Minister were
interpreted as pointing to further
output cuts a barrel of Brent crude will
currently set you back 78 15 cents a bow
that is up nearly 1 and three quarter
percent on the session but joining me
this morning is Rachel winter she's a
partner at kilikenko Rachel good to see
you uh we we really got to start with
Marx and Spencer haven't we I mean uh
shot the lights out
yeah they have so this is a company
that's been struggling for a long time
the shares are down 60 over five years
it's really kind of lost its way on the
fashion side it's had all these
Rachel can you hear me
yes oh
there we go the The Perils of outside
broadcasting sorry Rachel you were
telling me all about marks and Spencer I
was yeah so they've been really
struggling for many years the shares are
down to 60 over five years and people
have really been waiting for some sort
of turnaround and looking at the share
price this morning some investors
clearly think that that turnaround is
happening I think what investors are
most excited about is the dividend which
is being reinstated the company is
suspended the dividend at the start of
the pandemic investors were very
disappointed because UK investors really
love our dividends and then the results
are smiling the company announced it
would be reinstating that dividend in
November this year
it's quite a busy day for uh company
updates today Rachel another uh
highlight was SSE one of the few gainers
on the ftse this morning
yeah so I think a lot of people think
SSE is an electricity supplier it
doesn't actually do that anymore it's
really changed its business around and
now it's really focused on generating
more Renewable Power and it's actually
in the process of building the world's
biggest offshore Wind Farm it's really
benefited over the last year from higher
power prices but so for that reason its
profits were 89 higher so really really
really good results here it has
announced it will be erasing its
guidance for the next year and because
of its focus on Renewable Power it does
expect its profits from the renewable
division to be up by 20 per year over
the next five years so I think this is
really one of the most exciting
companies in the ftse 100 at the moment
and Rachel what did you make of seven
Trent I mean obviously this company's
walking a bit of a tightrope because
obviously they've got a generator return
for their shareholders but the whole
industry is in the spotlight right now
over sewage spills so they can't really
be seen to be uh making uh too much
money if you like
exactly so there's been a huge amount of
negative press about the water industry
for all these sewage bills and it was
interesting when I looked at their
update this morning normally for any
company update you would start with the
financials but for seven thread this
morning the opening lines were all about
the environmental credentials so they
really are focusing on this very heavily
the shares are down today and actually I
don't think that's because of their
results I think it's because of the UK's
inflation reading this morning so the
inflation reading was higher than
expected that means interest rates are
likely to go higher and that will send
bond prices down a lot of people treat
the shares of water companies as though
they are bonds because they're seen as
quite boring and they pay out regular
coupons in the form of interest payments
and for that reason they tend to trade
like bonds so when bond prices come down
we tend to see the shares of water
companies coming down to and that
certainly has happened with seven
friends and all of its competitors this
morning
I'm Rachel a quick word on the
Kingfisher obviously it was a very very
rainy March but they still have some
bits of the business that are doing
extremely well like Screwfix for example
yes it's been a difficult time I think
for this company because they did so
well in lockdown because people were
going crazy for DIY and things have
naturally slowed down a bit the housing
market has slowed down which is bad news
for them but as you say there certainly
are some bright points in particular
people are spending more on making their
houses more sustainable so there has
been an increase in the sales of things
like Loft insulation and also they are
doing well online so before the pandemic
about seven percent of their sales took
place online and that's now up to about
17 so there certainly are some bright
points in this update today
all right Rachel got to leave it there
pity weren't uh able to come and join me
in North London here today see you soon
yes exactly we'll have a good day
still to come here from the podcast show
before we get on to that bit of breaking
news for you um I've just been told that
Rishi sunak the Prime Minister has
written to uh suela bravam and the uh
the Home Secretary to say that uh her
conduct over the recent speeding fine
that she incurred has not been a breach
of the ministerial code we will have
more on that story throughout the
morning here on Sky News at we get it
but still to come here from the pop car
show
I'm gonna be joined by a celebrity here
we're going to have a listening party
with Tim Burgess from the charlatans
coming up next
[Music]
thank you
how are you feeling
strong
Almighty crush it was like night foul
can you hear that Mark the game is up
he's going to have to stand down the
Majesty Queen Elizabeth II has died
against the dollar ever ever I am
resigning hopes of reaching Britain
dashed at least for today
[Music]
thank you
so we're coming straight to you
welcome back we're live from the podcast
show here in North London my next guest
first achieved famous the lead singer of
the charlatans but over the last few
years he's gained many new fans as the
host of Tim's listening party during
lockdown Tim Burgess had the idea of
gathering Twitter users to listen to
albums together in real time since then
he and his followers have digested and
discussed more than a thousand albums
and the listening party is now in
podcast form via absolute radio we're
Tim continuing to share records
alongside some of his favorite artists
and are very pleased to say he joins me
now Tim welcome to you good to see you
what made you hit on the idea in the
first place after listening on Twitter
um well I've been doing it for a little
while with just the charlatans but it
occurred to me um during lockdown that
you know people were looking for things
to do and uh and it seemed like a
helpful thing to do to encourage other
artists to get involved on on my Twitter
platform I mean that was what really
made a success at the fact that I mean
I've listened to a few myself you know
you had Steve Hanley from the fall oh
yeah um Peter Hook from uh Joy Division
and New Order of course I mean that's
what really gives it some extra Pizzazz
isn't it well you know as Stephen and
hooky uh you know Heroes of mine and um
and uh but um you know we kind of spread
it out to new artists and and artists
that um you know are heroes of other
people you know there's over a thousand
that we've done
um we were doing at least three a day
um and at the weekends like 10 a day so
it was kind of quite chaotic but it's
fun so now it's turned into a radio show
and a podcast of course what was the
impetus for that well um lots of people
would say to me that um it should be a
podcast
and I was like great you know let's just
turn it into that and and um uh some uh
somebody offered me my friend offered me
a a job
um being a radio presenter broadcaster
which you know I'm still getting to
grips with it's not quite um you know
behind the scenes on on Twitter but yeah
I'm getting quite into it and did you
need to sort of do a lot of the
technological stuff yourself the the
sort of nuts and bolts of podcasting if
you like
um well I have a lot of help
you know but but it's become bigger
presumably it's quite difficult for you
presumably you've got now people coming
to you saying can you feature our album
I mean that's yeah tricky well it's it's
been like that
um you know I mean the first three weeks
on Twitter during the lockdown there
were people that I knew or people that I
could DM on Twitter
um and then it became like just open to
everybody you know they would contact me
at brand new albums
um
uh you know and people that have really
wanted to meet and never thought I'd
have the chance to and with with the um
with the radio show so far we've had
YouTube Fallout Boy
um we've got the Bangles and uh Texas
and um uh you know we've got sparks
coming up and Matt Johnson from the so
just really you know just really
wonderful engaging artists who want to
talk about music which is what the
show's about how much of this because
you're still recording with the
charlatans of course which is I think
got a new album coming out fairly soon
haven't you well we don't know about
that we're trying to find out what our
sound is actually like in 2013 but um
I'm heading up to Manchester today to to
ask everybody else what they think but
is is this then a distraction from the
job of making records
well to me you know I love music so it's
all part of the same thing
um and and it's I making a record is
like investigating what you sound like
or trying to work out how you
um connect with the other members of the
band
and where the listing part is it's just
talking to musicians and and getting the
connection with other musicians so it's
it's a beautiful way of exploring music
really I mean you're obviously
passionate about what you're doing
passionate about music obviously but
there is a commercial side to this now
have you had to compromise artistically
in any way at all
um I don't think so I mean not not not
in any way no not really I was trying to
I was trying to you know give you a very
um you know honest answer but um
the thing about listening practices is
is it if everybody was my personal taste
then it wouldn't really go that far
because mine's quite an Eclectic taste
um so you have to spread it out to
everybody so everybody's included so if
someone comes along that I might not
know their music then who am I to say
whether it's good or not yeah no I've
got to ask you Tim you've been quite
critical in the past about how much
Spotify pay artists and you've made a
comment particularly when spotify's
founder said he'd try and buy Arsenal
Football Club
you're in bed with these people now you
know what I mean it's kind of I mean
again with the listening party you know
I I it couldn't just people couldn't
just play an album or a CD you know you
have to be able to stream a record
and I've I've complained about Spotify
and I probably still will you know I
think you know there has to be a fairer
solution that all artists get get you
know get a fairer share and and it's
important for new artists
um who would try to break through to be
able to get paid for what they do yeah
Amen to that Tim it's lovely to have you
on the program it's my pleasure thank
you thanks for having me good to see you
just going to return now to the uh
breaking news which I uh brought you
before the break which is that the Prime
Minister Rishi sunak has written to the
Home Secretary Sue Ella bravaman uh that
is to make clear that uh following an
investigation he does not believe that
uh suela bravaman has broken the
ministerial code this of course relates
to a speeding fine that she incurred
last summer we're joining me now on set
is our political correspondent Sam coats
uh Sam what do you make of this it's a
significant breaking news in
richardsonac has decided to keep home
secretaries Suella bravaman in post all
the way back on Saturday night the
Sunday Times and the men on Sunday
revealed that Zoella bravaman had been
having conversations with her officials
about her speeding penalty now it's
never been quite clear what exactly she
asked for did she ask perhaps for the
points to be canceled did she ask for
her officials simply to investigate ways
where she could go for a speed awareness
course but not be seen by other
participants perhaps do it uh privately
now there is an allegation that the
labor party made that this breached the
ministerial codes and if you bring some
ministerial code then potentially you
are out now at the time Richard sunak
was uh at the G7 in Japan he has
returned to the UK looked at the matter
looked at the emails uh underlying the
matter and this morning uh there's been
an exchange of letters that makes clear
that Richard sunak is keeping suela
bravaman in place let me just a little
bit of the letter Richardson says I have
consulted with my independent advisor
and that's Laurie Magnus who he brought
in to look at things like this and he is
advised on this occasion no further
investigation is necessary and I have
accepted that advice on the basis of
your letter in our discussion my
decision is that these matters do not
amount to a breach of the ministerial
code so she's he Rishi sunak is going to
make the argument on the basis of the
facts not that we've got but that he's
got that Zoella Brotherman should stay
in place it has to be said that had he
taken the alternative course of action
to force her to resign there would have
been a huge route around with the right
of the party around at a point where
it's the home secretary's brief on
Thursday coming onto scrutiny with
possibly 750 000 being the figure for
the latest net migration uh he's decided
not to have that route to keep her in in
place but people will accuse like labor
are of British in that being weak all
right Sam thanks for that I know Mr
puller I demotivated demoted you there
definitely political editor Sam could
see it
still to come here live from the podcast
show
when we first started out all we had was
each other and no songs no Roxanne no
message in a bottle no no Every Breath
You Take he hadn't started writing them
yet
we're going to be continuing with the
music theme with the host of the
successful rock on tours podcast Gary
Kemp and Guy Pratt stay with us
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
welcome back we're continuing the
Musical theme now on Ian King live here
at the podcast show rock on tours is a
podcast that aims to tell the real
stories behind real music it's presented
by Spandau ballet's Gary Kemp and the
bassist guy Pratt who's work with
everyone from Pink Floyd to Madonna
between them they've managed to attract
the likes of Mick Hucknall Cheryl Crow
and Marianne faithful to their podcast
and this week they're going live for the
first time with a punk special Gary
kembank guy Pratt are with me now
gentlemen welcome to you both where did
the idea for rock on tours come from I
suppose it came from we play with Nick
Mason from Pink Floyd in in sourceful of
Secrets and we were on tour about four
years ago and on the bus all we spoke
about well it came about because I
actually brought a box set of old old
gray whistle test DVDs so we just sat on
the bus watching these old performances
and you just chat and gossip and of
course Nick always had great personal
reminiscences about a lot of these
artists yeah and you know people just
sort of said like you two really should
get a podcast actually it was guy's idea
and uh and of course we have a good
phone book between us you know you do I
mean it's it's very very relaxed I mean
it just sounds like you're just chatting
to Old Pals most of the time which I
guess is what you're doing that's kind
of the idea I mean because people
because we're not journalists people
will talk to us and it's you know in a
way it's like blokes down the pub I mean
it's very much we are our audience it's
the same thing you know but what because
what is amazing is that even people we
know really really well we always find
out stuff we didn't know you know Nick
Mason told me something I've never know
I've known the guy for 40 years yeah I
think
um people in the business you know other
musicians tend to open up a little bit
more to us I mean we had
Mick Fleetwood got extraordinarily
emotional didn't they on the show
because when he was talking about how he
just had one dream to get Lindsay and
everyone back on stage again
um I I think it's that the vibe is that
it's a sort of AAA pass with three
musicians backstage having a chat and
and that's how we keep it it's never
journalistic yeah what about the
reaction from the listeners who got the
biggest reaction
I said I think it was Mick fleeberg
wasn't that Mick fleeberg got a very big
reaction yeah I think he's still been
our most popular uh podcast
um the the 70s and the 80s are where our
Heartland really is isn't it I mean and
no of course Noel Gallagher
90s but um yeah I think Noel always
seems to attract people
so who haven't you had on yet that you'd
love to get on well so there's Peter
Paul and Pete
Peter Gabriel Paul McCartney Pete
Townsend hey Ann Rolling Stone would be
lovely yeah I mean all of which we know
but they're obviously the hardest people
to convince that it's worth coming on
the podcast yeah do you have to do you
get people coming to you now saying
please have me on yeah no that's
absolutely I think you know PR companies
have started to to know about us I mean
I think people are happy to come on
because there isn't that sense of being
interrogated that you know I think we
all as musicians are used to feeling
when we do other journalistic podcasts
um and I think people just know that we
have like-minded experiences to them
that's actually yeah some of the nicest
ones have been when someone's come on
who clearly doesn't where we're part of
a promo round they don't know who we are
they don't really think of us is and
then you get sort of a few minutes in
and they're going oh hang on this is
really nice these guys are great I think
what we like about it the most is that
guy and I are best friends and we we
have good banter and and and and it's
great to once a week just to sit down
for an hour and have a yeah have a
moment with each other yeah it's great I
mean do you think the podcasting
represents a threat to live radio at all
yes yeah no I don't well I didn't say
something newsworthy no I mean I I
probably would more more listen to
podcasts generally than I do live radio
even if it might be a podcast from that
was originally on live radio
um which you know the BBC had been doing
um so yeah it's because it's a threat
absolutely yeah now you're taking the
format live tomorrow you've just up the
road at the screen on on the green with
a punk special why have you gone for
that particular theme it's an iconic
thing it's it's there are certain things
that keep coming up in the podcast no
matter who took all sorts of people have
weird references to prog rock and
there's this legendary gig that happened
at the screen on the green on August
29th 1976 which was where the Buzzcocks
The Clash and the Sex Pistols played one
of us might have been there
so it's it's been a source of ribbing
and a bit of uh yes uh tomorrow night my
humiliation is complete yes it is and
we've we've had um Glenn Matlock on
before but yeah we're going to be just
discussing that night which is a real as
guy says seminal moment in in rock music
where you know it changed my life and it
it was the beginning really the birth of
of that incredible movement so is this
the precursor to doing more live events
in future that we'd love to I mean yeah
yeah I mean yeah I think that's
absolutely the way podcasts work now you
know that you know you listen to your
favorite podcast but you would really
dearly love to be in the audience I mean
what's going to be interesting for us is
to see what they look like because yeah
you know we don't kind of know what they
look like yet might be nasty surprise
for you that's not a nice thing for the
audience to hear they're going to be
thinking we are sitting up there
wondering what we look like oh yeah yeah
they better smarten up right before I
let you go you your career I think began
on the prices desk at the financial
times my God it did you're right how did
you know that you could because a
meeting mine used to work with you
I made a few screw-ups as well I think I
did more to damaged uh capitalism than
any copy of socialist worker you could
have been a financial journalist where
did it all go wrong
Gary guy great to see you both thank you
thank you very much
well we're going to move away from
podcasting for just a moment because one
of the sectors that's been most affected
by the sharp rise in interest rates
during the last 17 months is commercial
property there's growing evidence that
higher interest rates have started to
hit property values as well as chipping
away at the confidence of developers
well among the bigger players in
London's West End is great Portland
Estates it owns office and Retail sites
both there and in the city of London
well today it announced a pre-tax loss
of 164 million pounds for the year to
the end of March that compared with a
profit of 166.7 million pounds in the
same period a year earlier and reflected
a decline in the value of its property
portfolio well joining me now is Toby
kortold he's chief executive of great
Portland Estates Toby good to see you
this morning I mean everything that
you've done is in common with all of the
other big names recently you've written
down the value of your portfolio I guess
the point to stress is this is a
non-cash write Dan
that's right it's a it's a valuation uh
fall as a result of rising interest
rates as you've referenced in and it's
not surprising really given what's been
going on in uh in financial markets over
the last uh a year or so uh but I think
actually it's less of a fall than many
marketing commentators were expecting
largely because of where our assets are
so they're right in the middle of
Central London predominantly West End
and because the demand from our
customers has been very robust and in
fact we've just announced a record
quantity of leases for the year
something like 56 million pounds worth
and they have been signed ahead of the
estimates that the value has told us we
should be leasing them for so in fact
the valuation boils down is less down
than the market was expecting uh and
indeed we beat our principal uh uh
Benchmark being the msci index by a full
five percentage point so not bad
and very interestingly Toby I mean
you've actually had a record year for
lettings in spite of this sort of
markdown in asset values
we have and we've seen great demand from
both large corporations and smaller
companies as well London one of its
great enduring strengths has been its
magnetism for both big and small we've
brought Clifford chance back from Canary
Wharf to the core City we're building
their new HQ for them and I think that's
a really positive sign for the center of
town and in our smaller spaces our Flex
offer which is a fully serviced offer uh
has seen some strong income growth and
strong demand as well and we fully
expect that to continue so some good
numbers coming out there too
yeah I mean Clifford chance moving back
from The Wharf to the city is quite a
big thing what about the supply and
demand Dynamics right now for office
space in in London
so really interestingly we we've tracked
for a long time uh the supply of new
space
um we think there is something like an
80 shortage uh of new space coming out
of the ground over the next four years
and that's almost the highest we've ever
seen it and if you look specifically in
the core of the West end where the
majority of our assets sit we think the
prime vacancy rate so this is new great
quality spaces is around 0.6 so in
average on average people will talk
about a vacancy rate that's much higher
than that and that doesn't really affect
us so much because of where our assets
sit and at the prime level 0.6 is a
remarkably low number so if you're
looking for great quality space in
central London you are going to struggle
to find it and it is for that reason
that we've been pre-leasing uh many of
the uh the buildings that we've been
delivering as customers look out uh into
the Middle Easterns find that there's
very space available and have to forward
by it from developers like us which is
which is a a reflection really of that
shortage and I don't see that easing up
anytime soon planning is as hard as ever
and clearly with refinancing challenges
uh having gone up with interest rates
having risen a lot of companies are
going to struggle to raise the capital
needed to build and invest in new spaces
and clearly with our gearing down at
under 20 we have the balance sheet to be
able to invest in future development
from here which is very encouraging
yes you've always run the business very
conservatively I mean what you've just
said of course Toby has massive
implications for a rental growth over
the next few years
yes and we we've this morning published
our own prospective growth rates we're
forecasting Prime office rents in our
portfolio to grow over the next 12
months between three and six percent
that's an increase from our previous
estimates so some of that optimism
around a supply shortage and the demand
that we're seeing for our spaces right
now is giving us the confidence to
increase our expectations over the next
12 months
Toby we've just mentioned uh the fact
that you've done a pre-letting deal with
with Clifford chance there's a lot of
talk about AI right now and how it's
going to disrupt various Industries the
legal profession being one of them do
you worry that AI is going to destroy
jobs and that in turn hits rental demand
in future
um I I I think it's going to be a more
complex uh picture than perhaps that
suggests no question some jobs uh will
disappear into the ether uh into AI into
all sorts of uh different Arenas that's
always been the case but at the same
time new technologies generate an
enormous amount of new jobs and one of
London's great enduring strikes frankly
for the last a thousand years has been
its ability to reinvent itself and
attract the brightest and the best from
around the world to come and seek their
fortunes and their and their livelihoods
in this great City investing and putting
their own time and energy into new
things AI is clearly one of those it
comes with many Health warnings as as we
all understand but I'm not worried that
in cities that have a really important
purpose like London does central London
does I'm not worried that AI uh disrupts
to the extent that it removes the depths
of its employment largely I think
because people people like to be
together they like to uh to come
together to think to create uh to have
fun and great cities like London provide
that in Spades and I don't see that
changing
okay Toby we've got to leave it there
busy day for your results day we do
appreciate you spending the time to chat
to us thank you
now most people know Dolby the audio
technology company for its surround
sound in cinema and home entertainment
systems but it's also taken its
technology into podcasting with Dolby
Atmos which it claims to go beyond the
traditional surround sound systems and
create a more immersive effect for
podcasters joining me now is Rob France
he's head of global content engineering
at Dolby Laboratories Rob welcome to you
put Dolby Atmos into the broader context
for me the wider Dolby Laboratories
business of course well Dolby Atmos is
one of our premium entertainment
experiences and for years now it's been
available in the cinemas in home
entertainment as you say there's a wide
range of content already available in
Dolby Atmos but the way we work in all
our Technologies is really looking to
bring together a few key Partners to
enable these Technologies to be
experienced in the home and so we bring
together content creators who are
creating spectacular audio and of course
for Dolby Atmos that's about mixing in
3D and creating these great sounding
movies and TV shows we then to bring
together the services so the likes of a
Netflix or a sky TV Who deliver Dolby
Atmos to consumers in the home but sort
of the core business for us is
ultimately getting devices to integrate
Dolby Atmos and the major markets for is
there are like the TVs mobile phones
audio and smart speakers and these types
of categories and so that's where our
business is about this but ultimately
we're looking to bring each of these
together in all of these content areas
and we have major Partners across our
board so it's a logical progression to
go into podcasting I mean I'm struck by
the fact that you're running special
lessons for uh for sound engineers and
technicians on that is it is it quite a
daunting technology for people to get
their heads around so it's not a
daunting technology to get around but as
with all things it's like people like
that opportunity to train and get out of
their day job to actually spend the time
to learn something new and so we've long
since run training for people mixing in
Dolby Atmos and before that in our
previous Technologies because we think
educating creators in how they can use
the technology is the best way in
getting those spectacular entertainment
experiences because what we do see is
that you know we can create these
technologies that get content into the
home into cars into mobiles but actually
it's working closely with the creative
professionals where they really bring it
to life and so this is how my podcast
should sound this is how my my music
track should sound and they're the ones
who know it should sound we can just
help them in that process and you
partnered with the likes of audible who
are now bringing it into uh their audio
books how do the revenues break down
that you get a revenue share or is it a
sort of flat fee they pay you well as I
said our business is really driving
around consumer licensing so if we look
at how our business structures I've
talked about this like content services
and devices then device licensing is by
far the biggest part of our business and
if we look at Dolby Atmos and Dolby
Vision which is our video take
technology we group those together and
they've sort of grown 30 year and year
but ultimately our Revenue will come
from licensing into cars into smart
speakers and into mobiles and we've seen
huge growth in that area over the coming
years I was going to say I mean Dolby is
an eight billion dollar company I mean
podcast presumably is a fairly small
part of the uh the revenue mix well when
we talk about content in Dolby we want
everybody to get the best possible
experience and allow creators whatever
they create to to deliver those
experience and so we see podcasts as a
growing segment you know obviously we
don't have many podcasts in Dolby Atmos
today that's part of why we're at the
show we're here to give creators that
experience of what a really good Dolby
Atmos experience can be and the other
thing that I think has come together at
this time is the devices that people
listen to podcasts on are really
becoming Dolby Atmos equipped so we've
had many mobiles for years you know
people listen to podcasts on mobiles in
the car and on Smart speakers there's
hundreds of millions of mobiles out
there Apple iPhones Samsung Galaxy
phones all featured Dolby Atmos
technology but now we're seeing growth
in smart speakers Sonos era 300 was
launched recently JBL announced the
Boombox that's going to feature Dolby
Atmos but more recently we've seen cars
as well so many Mercedes models a few
Volvos and other things coming too Rob's
just the right time to be good to see
you gotta leave it there thanks for
joining of course thank you that's it
from me from the podcast show here in
North London don't forget our podcast
you can catch that up as well Kimberly's
up next with the build up to pmqs I'll
see you tomorrow back in the studio
cheerio
thank you
[Music]